so i always i want to you know i think
we asked rob the same thing
he just moved it he just moved to
arizona where i'm from yeah
not to change subject but he's moved out
there and he goes hey you live out there
i'm moving there
i go if you want i get i got a guy that
could show you around right i know i
live here
[Laughter]
you were just moving there one second
and then he goes no i'm here
yeah yeah and he goes [ __ ] hot as
[ __ ] man what do you do
am i turning maybe the camera should be
in front of me
anyway it's like more over there
you know i sort of split between you
guys so maybe you put it there now yeah
yeah yeah
i don't eat i don't know i don't do
podcasts don't listen to me
so but my chair keeps spinning this way
yeah so that's where you get you might
you know my mom lives in gilbert arizona
oh yeah i know where that is yeah yeah
how what part of arizona is this stock
was it
scottsdale scottsdale yeah that's where
i grew up but gilbert's pretty close so
so schneider goes hey uh
first it's really hot we know he'd be
moved to the worst time
then he goes uh hey my wife got bit by a
scorpion
an arizona bar scorpion got bit by a
scorpion already like within a month
that's pretty quick
yeah yeah and those scorpions are deadly
in arizona the bars scorpions are scary
i i um
i was when i got some money from old
tommy boy a long time ago i went
bought a house in arizona and i had uh
and it was called a model house so they
show you
this is the house they show you and if
you want them to build one
i didn't know that so it has every extra
amenity in case you want it like oh it's
got the sleek there's a little fountain
in the front you have to add that if you
build them yeah
and i go how about this one and they go
oh well
we can sell you this one but we have to
show it for a year
and so they work that here i buy it and
then they ran it back for me for a year
because i was doing the show i was like
i don't care
yeah and then i'll have every amenity
right that's what i thought so i did it
and then they had to build a hundred
houses around it right
yeah so the the bummer was when i
finally moved in
they're breaking ground in the desert so
all the scorpions come to me
i found 18 in two years
18. and you know there's way more these
are the ones that are out
you know
they're the ones that the balls are like
oh it's like a pixar movie
he is here so i was on i was on a
speakerphone once talking to some
lady friend and i'm in my uh boxers and
and my bare feet and then i go whoa whoa
hang on
oh oh i see i got a scorpion it's coming
right at me and she goes what i got a
scorpion i got to jump off
and she goes oh my god i had a ladybug
on my shower curtain
i go um i'm gonna die and you almost had
good luck can scorpions kill you
the arizona bars are like one of the
most poisonous ones and then on top of
that arizona has their
entomologist and then they have the
recluse spiders there
oh yeah the brown recluses because i
used to live in vegas and we used to get
the similar scorpions out there
you'd get a rag tag team from arizona
dude
i would if you said would you rather get
by bit bit by
rattlesnake scorpion wolf spider which
is a brown rick or
a black widow here's the order i would
take to regul to get bit
okay scorpion
rattlesnake yeah wow
black widow then wolf's butt i don't
know if that's what oh
that's right so it depends what kind of
rattlesnake because
somewhere less like the pacific
rattlesnake maybe not
different why does she know everything
she's [ __ ] bright
there's sidewinders diamondback not the
diamond
that's what we had mostly sidewinders
and diamondbacks okay so you're saying
you would first get bit by a scorpion
and i wouldn't i probably wouldn't go to
the hospital
where are you getting bit it depends
where nutsac
okay so scorpion first rattlesnake
what's your third
black widow what used to be black widow
was last but if you throw in wolf's
fighter
i would reckless would be my last yeah
that's what i'm saying that's why i said
black widow you know black widows will
[ __ ] you up but i would still say wolf
spider last because they cave in your
skin like
yeah it's like a bump and then a bigger
bump and then it's like a
sinkhole because they eat the tissue
underneath
that's cool yeah what do you mean
well the toxin basically melts your
tissue away so when you get bit by a
recluse
it it like he said it's first toxin yeah
and then it's just a giant gaping hole
underneath yeah like your arm goes and
then it goes like caves
so if a brown recluse bit me right here
on the cat holy [ __ ]
is that a nipple that looks like a nip
that's not even bad because
i've seen more like necrotic ones where
it's like the whole flesh is dug out
because i'm jacking off hey why is there
why is there edamame in it
japanese wow so bro i never realized
that brown recluses
were that they are scary dude
yeah yeah i mean this thing needs a
couple quick fixes but
not for this time yeah see it keeps
going that way
um what do you have the biggest heebie
jeebies about like what kind of animals
scares me yeah you know i heard
it doesn't scare me but i heard a bunch
of coyotes fighting this morning like
when they find a dog
at about four or five in the morning
yeah yeah they yep they live on the
hills
yeah dog in the middle going what the
[ __ ] because they go
searching for them yeah and when they
see him on the streets
this video too right when they see if i
come up my street i see a coyote
they they don't care at all not scared
they go like this
they pull your car and they go
yeah then they go into the bushes but
they don't go
we were in a car when we went to the
desert last week
we were in the car when we took that
off-road and there was a coyote right
there
yeah and i'm in a [ __ ] jeep
right and he's just like i'm not moving
taking enough time
to cry and i don't know if they all you
well
you're our resident zoologist but do
they have they have rabies or is just
that they coyotes typically don't have
rabies like foxes can carry rabies
i think any animal can carry rabies if
something with rabies bit that animal
like we could carry a comedian could
carry rabies
do you know what the antidote is to to
getting rabies like if you ever get bit
by rabies you need to get like
14 shots to the abdomen they still do
that i think so
at old school i think they'd have that
fixed by now or at least in the
philippines they they still do that do
they
and the rattlesnake we were told to suck
it out is that true like
i think when you get bit by a
rattlesnake you're supposed to keep your
heart rate down and stay as calm as
possible on your on route to a hospital
because if your heart rate is fast then
you're actually spreading the toxins in
your body much faster i think the idea
was
my stepdad would say cut the two teeth
marks together
yeah in a line suck as much as you can
out spit it out
then cross your [ __ ] fingers my
stepdad
so we had in my room we had five
rattlesnakes
my brother would collect them i lived in
this crummy town
compromising town outside of scottsdale
about an hour so really on the way to
tucson like middle of nowhere
and brian my brother had five
rattlesnakes and a tarantula in this
little
cage um he had a boa and a python
before that but they both got loose in
the house and then that was it we never
figured out where they went
yeah so rattlesnakes uh we
so my stepdad comes home he was a little
bit of a boozy susie
and he came home and we were trying to
catch this rattlesnake out front to make
it six you know we found one
and when we had a old milk that's like a
gallon right did
you picture that empty yeah and then
we took two tennis racquets and you get
it behind the head and then you
put it in and then it curls at the
bottom then you put the top on
so that's how we caught the other one
now we're all like you know i'm like
8 10 and 12. me and my brothers yeah
we're trying to catch this rattlesnake
and my
drunk dad comes home and stepped up
and he sees this he goes what are you
trying to do we go we got to get it in
there and he goes well what are you
playing tennis with it you just grab it
by the neck
and you stick it in yeah when you put it
in it goes like this
and i'm like that's why you don't grab
it
i'm gonna go take a nap and i'm like wow
[ __ ] i bet you will
so he went in he's like this
then he lays down we're staring like
this
and his [ __ ] face starts oh and then
we wake him up and we
drive him straight to the hospital oh
wow he's drunk he fell asleep
and they were like you got him here just
in time and then they had to do
anti-venom and all this yeah well he
could have died
i think so it can make you really sick
yeah
but did you get along with your stepdad
i
did my step dad went a little crazy but
i i did we had the real dad he left
then there was a gap of no dad and then
there was a and my mom didn't date at
all
just three boys you know it's like she
had two jobs no way
wow and then step dad and then he went a
little
cuckoo what do you mean he uh
well he was in the army so we had all
these he had a lot of mental problems
uh ptsd yeah we didn't know then what
was
in what war i think it was vietnam one
of my favorites
really one of my favorites yeah is that
a top five for you no
just in terms of like the movies oh
because we watched the ken burns 10 hour
documentary not only that now that
platoon
nerd alert
platoon i know those are all bases right
all shot in the philippines
full metal jacket shot in the
philippines really glamorized
yeah oh philippines are we from yeah how
many philippines are there
seven thousand a hundred if you had a
gun in my head i would have said four
because i go how is everyone filipino
it's this big i literally thought it was
three islands of size of course
it's crazy because it's like i think
even smaller by landmass
smaller than um california but we have
over 100 million people so it's kind of
like
it's something because schneider's in
the tribe yeah it's part of the trade